[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] em
[Music]
happy hump day
how do you draw wedges on hump day we're
gonna talk about it today
that's right
I think it's a good thing
that Ron DeSantis is moving up in a
polls baby that gives us more to
politicize more to talk about more to
really make them think
about which fascists they want in charge
of their party because that's really the
question really isn't it
it's not like
Trump versus DeSantis
it's like which which fascist do we one
charge more
the one who did nothing for four years
is an absolute buffoon and a criminal
and probably going to be indicted or do
we want the fascist who set forth the
blueprint
for the fascist nation that we want
becoming more and more clear
that um that can stitch you and see the
constituents in this country of the uh
America First Nazi party
are coming to terms with that uh Donald
Trump has been irrelevant
it seems as if they're coming to terms
with that and the latest polls if you
believe polls at all would indicate that
Ron DeSantis is picking up a lead on
Donald Trump
not surprising this is good stuff though
you know you may you may you may try to
evaluate this and there may be a lot of
pundits are like this is terrible Ronda
Santos knows what he's doing he knows
the levers and the buttons to push to
turn this into a fascist Nation
oh well I mean that may be true
it may be true
but if you think
that Donald Trump isn't gonna absolutely
unleash
hell and fury
through his supporters on Ron DeSantis
you were not paying attention and let me
tell you something if there's a civil
war that we want to have happen in this
country it is between the [ __ ]
moglodytes that would be a Civil War I
would love to stand back and watch
they're gonna do it too they're all
right they've been doing it
and really if Rhonda santis gets in the
race next year because he's not he's not
gonna get in probably till the summer of
next year
and he's probably gonna wait till he's
down in the polls
because he knows he knows what him being
at the top of the polls mean it means
Donald Trump is gonna go on the offense
nicknames denigrating him posting on
fraud social about him
creating an Army against him
DeSantis knows this and DeSantis isn't
even in the race
but isn't it isn't it fantastic okay
bear with me here bear with me
and I and I know you know Tony you don't
know yes this is exactly what we need to
have happen
the race isn't even started we're
already talking about 2024 you God damn
right we're talking about the 2024
Republican primary votes
elections the primary elections
how do you think we're gonna bang them
up don't worry about the Democratic
nominee that's Joe Biden don't worry
about it
you you have you do not have to have to
wrestle your little head at all
it is going to be Joe Biden
mark it down no one is going to
challenge it how the [ __ ] would anyone
and the Democratic party challenge one
of the most effective presidents in our
modern history
no that's not gonna [ __ ] happen
people
so stop stop dreaming about it really
stop wasting your energy on it
let Joe Biden be effect Be an Effective
president let the administration Be an
Effective Administration
what we need to do is politicize the
absolute
nonsense
and buffoonery of the America First Nazi
party the Republicans
and they're gonna make it easy they're
gonna trust me they're gonna make it
easy you remember how easy it was the
[ __ ] goof
on Herschel Walker oh it's it's gonna be
just that easy in this primary and
remember that is the race they're
running they're not running against Joe
Biden and they're not going to Trump is
not going to let any of these
[ __ ] run against Joe Biden he
is going to force them to run against
him and he is going to run I don't give
a [ __ ] what you say what you're what
your [ __ ] theories are about ah he's
just using this for this or that
if you think that Donald Trump doesn't
have the absolute [ __ ] ego the ego
he's a megalomaniac this guy is going to
even if his goal is just to fend off a
trial or indictment which he's not going
to fend off indictment the best case
scenario is going to fend off a trial
which I think he will
with the timing of it
I actually do not think that we will
have a Donald Trump criminal trial in
the federal court system until 2025
Market
mark it down he'll be indicted before
then he's not going to go to trial
that's what this whole [ __ ]
Shenanigans of running in 2024 is
but with Donald Trump running in the
Republican primary remember that this is
not a general election folks
he is not going to allow Ron DeSantis or
any other of these [ __ ] chuckleheads
to run against anybody but him
that's why that's why they're that's why
they're not going to jump in right away
you're not going to see Ron DeSantis
jump in this race or anyone else
because they have to run against him
they're gonna wait until he's indicted
until he's damaged he's really banged up
and then they might jump in
because they got a fundraise they gotta
[ __ ] get get they gotta get money you
can't run without money
you remember the the 2020 Democratic
primary everyone thought Joe Biden was
done because he was broke until he got
to South Carolina he won South Carolina
and the money started to flow
and that's why Joe Biden is president
today
he owes a lot to Clyburn
a lot
and the black community to be frank
they voted him in
as the Democratic primary and that's the
important part here
about about this election that this
[ __ ] bonehead has already tried to
start the cycle for
he's already trying to start the cycle
and he he had to really
I mean what are the choice did he have
he has to remain some sort of relevant
imagine waiting until next year after
Jack Smith indicts him in Ron DeSantis
is way up in the polls and trying to
mount a presidential campaign it felt
flat
he had to strike the iron after the 2022
midterms he had no choice that's the
beauty of this
that's why they're weak and we should
take advantage of it by politicizing the
ever loving [ __ ] out of it
at every waking moment we should be
drawing wedges between any Republican
anywhere against their opponent a
Republican
that's what we should be doing
day in Day Out
is making them run against each other
which they're going to
and then on top of that the other thing
that we have to do with the politicism
politicization Jesus Christ and the and
the narrative in this country and the
messaging
is make the other
American first Nazis decide I don't know
if you noticed this but Maga land is
really having a difficult time figuring
out is Donald Trump going to actually be
a contender for the nomination or is it
going to be Ron DeSantis they can't
figure this [ __ ] out
well you should force them to make
statements you should force them
with our narrative we should force them
to take a Direction
that's going to be important and it
doesn't matter listen to me it doesn't
matter who their nominee is
okay I I know you think it does
but the choice between Ron DeSantis and
Donald Trump at this point which maybe
neither one of them are the nominee I
actually believe Donald Trump is going
to be the nominee
I believe that wholeheartedly
he he is going to absolutely burn down
every single one of these [ __ ]
what what is he gonna have to lose
he's gonna need to secure the nomination
at any any cost necessary
to fend off a federal criminal trial
listen to me that is why he's running
he's gonna be indicted he knows it his
attorneys know it the doj knows it why
in the [ __ ] do you think they [ __ ]
appointed Jack Smith the special counsel
it's gonna happen he's going to be
indicted
I don't know if you paid attention but
they they called Brad rattisberger
the Georgia Secretary of State you know
that the famous perfect phone call where
he was asking him to commit election
fraud
on behest of him so he could win
[ __ ] out of here
he's gonna be indicted folks the problem
is
is that even if he's indicted right and
and went over this before even if he's
indicted sometime the beginning of next
year which maybe will get a Christmas
present but January February maybe March
first quarter right
Jack Smith strikes
with an indictment it won't be the only
one just be the first one
but let's say let's say he's indicted in
the beginning of the year you don't
think that Donald Trump and his
attorneys have the wherewithal to Kick
the Can through the primaries
of a of a federal criminal trial
absolutely they will
they will be able to stall
a federal criminal trial through the
primary
and if he can go to the convention and
get the nomination
I don't see how a federal judge isn't
going
to stall a trial
and they're not going to undo the
indictment you can't undo an indictment
not how it works especially at the
federal level they just don't dismiss
charges
just because someone's a nominee
but they will they will
put off a trial
and that's where it comes to us again
it's us again who are the jury
we will be the jury in 2024.
especially if Donald Trump is the
nominee
I mean a better situation is he doesn't
get the nomination he runs
in several States on an independent
ticket
and these red States put him on the
ticket independently
more power to him [ __ ] them that sounds
really good to me
how would you like if the country has to
choose between Joe Biden Ron DeSantis
and Donald Trump on a three-way ticket
they are they would be absolutely [ __ ]
sounds good to me sound good to you
Donald Trump is toxic politically
but he's necessary
to the Republican party because they are
[ __ ] toxic Nazis
when you live in a trash Heap you need a
ton of garbage
to keep that trash sheet going
Donald Trump is just the answer to the
Trashy prayers
so this is exciting this morning
that Rhonda santis is pulling ahead
because this only means this only means
more public fighting
and it only means that Rhonda santis is
going to have to go on some offensive if
he plans on getting in this race at some
point
maybe he just plays defense I don't know
it's gonna be quite the show and we're
gonna get to watch
think about this
in the history of modern politics
presidential politics in particular in
this country
the media oh Democrats in this array
Democrats in disarray Democrats disarray
Democrats oh why is this bad for
Democrats why is this listen this is all
good for democracy
and you're going to have some pundits
are going to say he's full of [ __ ] Ron
DeSantis is horrible for democracy yeah
and democracy gets to make that decision
how how in the [ __ ] can you be so
pro-democracy yet not have faith in it I
don't understand that we went through
this in the 2022 midterm you had David
pakman uh uh The Young Turks all these
[ __ ] negative son of a [ __ ] out
there saying the Democrats are going to
lose and they believed all the [ __ ]
[ __ ] polls they believed the [ __ ]
media because they wanted to be correct
they wanted to be right and the evidence
showed that there was no way that there
wasn't going to be a red wave history or
the polls get the [ __ ] out of here who
gives a [ __ ] about that stuff
who cares if you're correct
have some [ __ ] faith in democracy for
crying out loud
if you truly are a pro-democracy person
and you're part of the pro-democracy
Coalition I don't care where you're on
the Spectrum whether you're a Democratic
Socialist a liberal a lefty
a moderate an independent
a never Trumper I don't give a [ __ ]
where you're at on the Spectrum I don't
care if you truly are down deep down
inside of you pro-democracy have some
[ __ ] faith in it
why do you think gen Z showed up
they have faith in democracy
they believe in it
is it perfect no
that's kind of the [ __ ] point
that it's not absolutely perfect
you're never gonna get
a policy set that's going to benefit
only you it's not gonna happen in a
nation
there's a lot of [ __ ] that live
here in this country
and when you set policy it's not going
to benefit every single person in the
same way
democracy is difficult I've been telling
you this for years authoritarianism
is the easy way out
it's the weak way
I mean look what look what is happening
to Twitter
I mean yeah is it a private company in a
private business but authoritarianism
has taken over over there
he's absolutely destroying any
credibility that Twitter even has
he'll probably destroy the entire
platform and have to sell it off for
pennies on the dollar because he's such
a dumb [ __ ] but the problem the reason
why he's such a dumb Buck is because
he's trying to be a dictator over there
[ __ ] does not know how
to run a company he's not smart Elon
Musk is not smart he's not bright at all
he's a dumb [ __ ] foreign
on and yes it does take a little bit of
ignorance to be deluded by Q Anon don't
let anyone tell you well smart people
can smart people can be deluded by a
cult sure absolutely but it's their
[ __ ] ignorance showing through
he's absolutely obviously bought into a
lot of this queuing on [ __ ]
and the Q Anon stuff is absolute
authoritarian garbage that's what it is
it's an alt-right movement
hello hello think
that's why he's destroyed Twitter
and destroying Twitter now will it
survive sure
what it'll look like you know who the
[ __ ] knows
God damn I guess he isn't even paying
rent over there
but is that what you want for our
country
no I don't believe that this country
wants authoritarianism I mean are there
a certain percentage of people in this
country that absolutely want one person
to tell them what to do and what to
think you [ __ ] ain't right they do
because they're they're white males and
they know that they benefit from white
males making decisions and making policy
based on one thing and one thing only to
give privilege to white males
hello I know this I've seen it I've
listened to it
so yeah there's a lot of [ __ ]
ignorant [ __ ] that want
authoritarianism because it's easy for
them
it's easy
why do you think I come here every day
for two [ __ ] hours yelling screaming
to this microphone
it would be so easy for me just to be a
right winger do you know that it would
be [ __ ] easy for me just to bend to
authoritarianism
and let my privilege pave the way
but I believe that I should use my
privilege to smash that [ __ ]
privilege [ __ ] that [ __ ]
why why why in this country does one
person get privilege over another it's
ridiculous in any democracy to be quite
honest
this is 2022 for crying out loud
we're still trying to stand around
figure out why diversity Equity
inequality is good get the [ __ ] out of
here
that's why I'm again that's why I'm
excited about gen Z they believe in
democracy
they believe they believe in compromise
folks
this narrative from the right the Gen Z
is some sort of cancer culture and
they'll Eat You Alive And they're
they're gonna cancel you well I mean if
you're a Nazi yeah you goddamn right
they're gonna cancel you
but what on Earth would a generation
that absolutely knows and believes in
diversity equity and equality
would they damage any sort of democracy
that's why I'm excited about that
generation
they believe in it they have faith in it
they want to engage in it
they want to know about our country
they're interested
and they understand that to get the
things that you you need and want in
this country you know a decent wage not
to go broke because of a medical bill
get a decent education without having
[ __ ] mountains of debt for your
entire [ __ ] life
have an affordable housing to where you
don't have to [ __ ]
choose food or a heat bill
those are things that gen Z wants
for themselves
because let's be frank
the generations before them some of them
got it handed to them
and some of them have struggled to get
there
they've they've noticed this
you don't think they know this
and the other thing about gen Z that
excites me the most is they understand
social media
there is never
been a generation
that has grew up in this country
and been formed by social media like gen
Z
they understand it they know it they
know what it is
even if the rest of us don't
they get it
years ago
when television became popular became on
the uh very very accessible on the
market they were worried about TV
brainwashing people you remember that um
you might remember this you can go back
and look at the stories they were
terrified oh TV's gonna brainwash people
it's gonna brainwash them oh my God
this country's doomed
one doomed here we are same thing with
video games I was the video game
generation it was gonna [ __ ] it was
gonna mind [ __ ] us and we were all gonna
be zombies and all kinds of [ __ ]
we're fine we're here we're right here
we did all right
was it perfect no it never is
and now social media and the internet
here we are and in 20 years we'll be
here
and gen Z will be leading this country
they will be the great leaders of this
country
but we have to make sure of it we not
just gen Z we have to band with them
and that's why we have to politicize
everything and every measure even if
it's a stupid little pole I don't the
poll is not right right this [ __ ]
pole with DeSantis and trumpet it's all
[ __ ] but who cares who gives a [ __ ]
we do not we do not have to
take every little thing and go oh well
well Tony says don't believe polls but
now he's saying believe this poll about
DeSantis and Trump I'm saying politicize
it
that's what I'm saying
use it to democracy's advantage that's
what I'm saying and I I actually uh
message
um my favorite political strategist Dr
Rachel bittickoff are you guys uh big
fans of Dr Rachel bittickoffer here on
the podcast
um she couldn't come on today but she's
gonna come on tomorrow I said hey I want
to talk about this topic
and um talk about actually driving
wedges and how to drive wedges between
Republicans as we get into this primary
season because again remember
selection that they're doing these polls
on [ __ ] or Not that we're going to
politicize
that we're going to use politics to win
elections for Democrats not Republicans
because we love democracy and they don't
they want to destroy it
this this election
is Republican versus Republican
and the greatest part about Donald Trump
being in this race is he is not going to
allow them to run against Joe Biden he
is going to force them to run against
him and that's the most important part
and that's why you come here every
single weekday so make sure to subscribe
down below if you're on YouTube
make sure to subscribe to these hump day
it's Wednesday tomorrow's Thursday
you'll be able to vote for bonehead of
the week so go to Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod you can vote on Twitter at
Tony Michaels pod follow us there and
also vote on YouTube again don't forget
to subscribe go hit that subscribe hit
the Bell notification you go to the
community tab on the YouTube channel
that the poll is there here's the
difference I think between
the Twitter bone end of the week pole
and the YouTube poll
so the the Twitter poll ends like you
set a timer on it
the YouTube poll I just put it up
there's no timer so you can go look at
all the polls and you can you can go
vote for them right now I mean it's not
gonna matter because we're not you know
we're not counting those votes
it's past election day on those
yeah but you know we allow you to vote
here
because we're Democrats and we love to
steal elections I don't know
uh Go download every single episode of
the Tony Michaels podcast on Apple
Spotify Google
make sure to leave us a great review
while you're there subscribing and if
you're on my just touch Facebook page
follow us at the Tony Michaels on
Facebook and download the Twitch app
if you like it's free and I don't get
anything for it people keep saying that
I can make money over on on Twitch
if if you like um if you type in your
Amazon thing Prime account or some [ __ ]
I don't I have no idea
I need to check into that one thing I
have been checking into speaking of
platforms and streaming to platforms is
I I'm still looking into this PornHub
thing
so we got any listeners out there that
know how to do the PornHub streaming
thing and maybe I'll tweet at them or
some [ __ ] I don't know
send them a message I think I have I
what I understand
is I have to become a model so I gotta I
gotta submit myself as a porn star
uh on PornHub to get the show there now
I'm not gonna put up any news I mean
unless you guys want them I might I
might consider consider it uh
I don't know if you guys would enjoy
that but but I I do want to put the show
on PornHub I think that would be that
would be great that would be fantastic
if we were on PornHub I think we would
draw a whole new audience to this show
and uh get people engaged in politics as
they're engaged in
other things
okay well uh we don't have any uh
Marjorie Taylor green butt plugs on the
merch store but go check out the merch
store anyways stored that the attorney
michaels.com you can still get your
Christmas
sweaters and hoodies the freedom to
oppress the rights of other people is
not Liberty these things are flying off
the shelves go to
store.dtonymichaels.com you can also get
your Rhonda Santa skin go [ __ ] himself
merch uh t-shirts coffee mugs so head
over there and get your Rhonda Santos
can go [ __ ] himself since Rhonda Santos
is in the news
we got a lot of [ __ ] to round up to uh
today on the [ __ ] list Roundup
um so don't go anywhere we'll be right
back
right after these messages
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
[Music]
I'm excited it's hump day who else has
ugly Christmas sweater parties who else
does anybody else doing the holiday
thing where you have ugly sweater
Christmas parties
don't know seems kind of fun what do you
think
I I I'm finally getting into the mode to
where we're um we're not
in the pandemic Mode still God damn it's
been two years two long years and we're
just getting back to uh some sort of
normal
um but you know I think you should get
out during the holidays and go visit
even your manga family to hell with it
go visit them
go visit them tell them how it is
I'll drop some facts
why not
drop some facts tell them what Q Anon it
really is
it's a cult I don't know have you have
you had more family members come around
because there's this there's this this
narrative and I think it's Republicans
trying to push this narrative which we
should push back on it that more and
more people are walking away from Trump
I don't believe that's true
I just I just don't believe that [ __ ]
I don't I don't see how a group of
people in Texas Paul um mentioned this I
believe this Tuesday or last Tuesday
it's all because they don't want to be
wrong right
they want to be correct they want to
keep going with the lines like they got
to keep it going they can't stop because
it would prove that they were full of
[ __ ] the whole time
and they can't be full of [ __ ] like they
can't do that
so maybe maybe that's a part of it you
know
and maybe that's what carries us into
2024 and delivers Donald Trump as the
nominee the Republican Party folks I'm
telling you he is the biggest [ __ ]
loser in American politics that we've
had in our country's modern history and
for him to be the Republican nominee
again is exciting
it's exciting
to me I'm I'm telling you and I know
people are like oh my God that's just
him being that close to the presidency
I actually believe there's more ways of
him being closer to presidency than him
being the nominee to be quite Frank
I don't think you're gonna let him in
2022 is a whole nother demographic
than it than it was even in 2022 excuse
me 2024 is a different different
demographic than it was in 2022 or 2020.
whole another [ __ ] ball of Wax
I mean you watch what happened in
Arizona with Gen Z they delivered they
delivered
a great outcome
in Arizona where they fended off a bunch
of [ __ ] qnr's election deniers
people who
I don't I don't know why they're doing
this
but it's almost like they want to go get
criminal charges placed against them
and that may be sort of the case here is
that they feel like they have to be
political prisoners or whatever the [ __ ]
you know whatever kind of [ __ ] that
they're spewing
now maybe that's it and I don't know
I don't know
but we'll see if uh if they trudge down
the road of criminal liability because
of their election denial it seems as if
a few would carry Leakes attorneys are
going to lose their law license
Gabe Sanchez is going to be joining us
here in just a few minutes
um
but I do let's see
I got a few we got a few things we want
to talk about today
and there's a few things trending um I I
didn't well I've never really watched
The Ellen Degeneres Show
um and apparently twitch the uh the DJ
on the show
um it's as in the news this morning
that he has uh he committed suicide and
um
it's always sad to watch such a talented
person even if you don't know them or
know their work much but it's always sad
to see such a very talented individual
take their own life
and it is a thing that no matter what
Walk of Life we come from what party
what affiliation
um mental health in this country is
something that we need to deliver to
every single person in this country
every single one of them I don't care if
you're here if you're inside of our
borders we need to make sure to take
care of our people
and the mental health of our people
and um it's just it's sad that someone's
so talented
and with such great future ahead of them
would take their own life and
um
you know
it's it's sad I I and again I I don't
even know his work
um but it's trending this morning on
Ellen Jenner's day you guys know uh
Brett my zealous
one of the uh Midas Touch Brothers I
worked for the Ellen DeGeneres Show
over at Ellen and um he gave a message
this morning
um about twitch let me see if I can pull
it up here
um
very heartfelt message
let's see if I can find it
and Brett knew him personally that's
what kind of hit close to home there but
that's why I bring it up because it is
now let's see if I can
here is the uh he was referring to the
TMZ report that Stephen boss
um again I I don't know his work but he
was the famed DJ on the Ellen DeGeneres
Show
and apparently he committed suicide and
Brett said no no no this can't be twitch
is one of the nicest and most talented
people I've ever met an incredible human
being his dressing room was across the
hall from my office for years I'm
completely devastated and in shock
rest in peace to it sending love to the
Boss family he's heartbroken so
um
as we as we watch
um the memories
of this talented person
we should remember that there are
thousands of people in this country that
suffer
from the same health and and need help
and reach out to anyone and you should
definitely
um be considering suicide hotlines today
and keeping keeping your family members
who have they may seem happy this kind
of reminds me because I watched a few
videos of twitch this morning seems like
such a happy person
um always upbeat that just because on
the outside just because on the outside
we're upbeat and we seem happy and we
seem like life is going well that does
not mean that on the inside it is going
well so always remember that
um and I think that's what we lack
especially especially on the right is
decency just [ __ ] just just simple
decency
um so I appreciate the message from
Brett this morning and I wanted to uh
bring up twitch there I think that's how
you see it I I again I I don't know I
never watched Ellen
I haven't ever watched on I don't I
don't watch a little a lot of daytime TV
as you can imagine hell I'm sitting here
talking to you most of the time
um but um and I and I don't know his
work but he definitely
um everyone giving him so many messages
he's definitely a talented individual
and it's sad to see
him take his own life the other thing I
want to bring up this morning while
we're talking about
um sadness is uh today is the 10-year
anniversary of Sandy Hook
um I can't even when I read it I was
like I had to double check to make sure
people weren't getting it wrong that
it's been 10 years
um since the children of Sandy Hook were
ripped apart by a a weapon of War
um you know you know that I am
absolutely
in favor of making sure we protect our
schools and our children in this country
by Banning assault weapons I don't give
a [ __ ] what they say that's what that's
what we need to do
um and and do it as fast as we possibly
can and it's just mind-boggling to me
mind-boggling to me that here we are 10
years after Sandy Hook and we're over a
year past Uvaldi
and we still are in a situation where we
can't we can't tell the truth to each
other
we cannot tell a truth to each other
it's absolutely insane
that we would have arguments over fences
and doors and more guns in school by
giving teachers and having armed
security guards this is all ridiculous
nonsense
so remember remember twitch this morning
and remember
um
those beautiful children at Sandy Hook
and their families
because it's it's important that we keep
it in our memory because if we do if we
forget about it we just move on
we will never
we will never reach a point
where our children's children will feel
safe in schools because we didn't do
something so right keep them keep them
in your memory I got Gabe Sanchez with
us Gabe Sanchez Health good morning my
friend good morning yeah so
um we had a birthday yesterday we forgot
yeah
um one of our moderators her son Phoenix
it's his 10th birthday so I won zero
that's that's that's a big one ten is a
big one man so like you got yeah you got
one of course it's a big birthday right
right right five because it's kind of
that number between you know one and ten
and then 10 is Big so I'm telling you
three years from now 13 is huge you got
another three years and then 16 and Mom
18.
but then then they're adults and it goes
by so fast and it really does a lot of
people cannot believe that I uh my son
my son is almost 18 years old
that's crazy and it's great wait he's
almost 17. but you know what I mean it's
almost an adult right yeah it goes by
quick I mean the other day fast the
other day I was I had this moment where
um
uh I I like I had this like it was like
a smell or a sound and like it was like
are you farting again or what no yeah
well it was you know my own batch
brought out whiff of nostalgia we'll say
but in that moment I like it doesn't
even matter what it was but in that
moment like brought me back to being a
kid really and what what what what point
in in your childhood did this bring you
was there a certain I wanna I wanna say
it was like maybe 14. oh okay maybe some
15 something like so not as young as
Phoenix not not right not as young but
it was a conversation I had with my
parents and it was like their friends
too and it was like some sort of like
family friend get-together and somebody
brought up the fact like
uh
uh they're like hey like don't try to
grow up too quick you know and I was
like what like I I want to be an adult
smoked cigarettes when you are that
young you just want people to take you
seriously be like no I'm I'm grown up
right I'm gonna joke I'm just right
exactly age yet yeah and now you want to
be 14 again and now you yeah right kind
of want to be 14 because you're like oh
my God if I would have really taken that
advice and it really is one of those
things where like because you hear you
hear your parents say like when I was
young I didn't listen to my parents and
they told me to really live in the
moment and understand
uh that that this this right here is
going to go away by so quickly and
you're gonna like be 10 years down the
line and you'll be like oh my god what
happened and it really was that moment
where I stopped and I was like oh my God
that was looking back not you know not
regret but a moment of like man my
parents were right for once you know I
wish I wish I was 16 years old for my
entire life that was like the greatest
time so Phoenix Phoenix Happy Birthday
Happy Birthday and don't get too old too
damn fast because 10 is a good age it's
a good age just so happy sit in it and
enjoy it that's right so happy birthday
to Phoenix everybody in the comments
um give a happy birthday 10th birthday
Big Ten to Phoenix boom boom
um so happy birthday to you Gabe Sanchez
the other thing I want to talk to you
about uh all politics here is um
yesterday you know it's Taco Tuesday oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah and I had tacos as
well okay what kind of tacos did you
have uh we had skirt steak okay do what
skirt steak it's a type of uh it doesn't
matter anyway it's a beef okay I guess
yeah there's like flank steak skirt
steak it's just you know it's dinner
it's mer you know you married
well you know um we talk a lot about
Taco Tuesday on here because we both
love tacos we both have a love for tacos
and and food in general I think but
um you know I I have learned a lot about
what tacos are and what tacos aren't
from Gabe Sanchez and um so I'm trying
to step up the Tuesday game and
yesterday I did chicken it was like
chicken ranch street tacos
um that's that was the you know I
wouldn't do the you know I'm not into
the ranch side of it oh you're saying
like Ranch like ranch sauce like I know
it was like it was like a seasoning then
it was oh okay the season that he used
like a like it was called I don't know
chickens Street Taco Ranch okay it was
good it was good they they're looking
they're you know you got an actual meat
in there right and I was wait I put beef
in there I put beef in there and I use
your family's um old recipe you know
like you said you um I I like the beef
seasoning that we like it's Old El Paso
remember I sent you a picture yeah yeah
that's the family recipe yeah right but
but uh but I so yesterday I did chicken
tacos and we got now here's here's the
thing and that Gabe Sanchez educated me
on did I no idea that I was doing wrong
the entire turn
I thought I was making tacos the entire
time and I'd make beef we'd have cheese
and tomatoes maybe some other stuff
beans or something if you wanted to put
it on there and we were putting them in
the big tortillas flowers the big ones I
did not know we were making burritos the
entire time I mean you pretty much are
just making open-faced burritos right
right which is pretty impressive because
there's a lot of surface area to cover
you know well you know you like to wrap
it you know
you're essentially making we were making
burritos yeah I had no idea I mean we
called then you but then those because
it's taco meat right right right but
then the photo you sent me last night
was like a little that's right well so
it so we we got
um they were called Street Taco they
were flowers street tacos yeah tortillas
yeah right and then you put the chicken
on and whatever fixes you want on there
so I'm learning a lot and I'm stepping
up my um my Tuesday game next week
um maybe I'll share a picture on here
yeah next week
um of like because I think next week I'm
gonna try steak not just beef there we
go some sort that's why I was interested
when you said something about some
special mistakes I'll I'll send you this
mistakes yeah and then uh yeah you could
do flour I know that you did or you did
it flour but you can do corn corn you
know toasted on the oh my god listen to
this guy this guy's really stepping up
my Tuesday you know get a little crisp a
little warm to it right right well it
happens yeah you put on top of the on
the grill or you put on the stove you
know heat it up yeah something like that
well you know you get a flat flat
surface hot flat surface put it on yeah
yeah so we get we get um a lot of stuff
to talk about today in the [ __ ] list
Roundup but I I don't know if you heard
did you know the work of twitch much is
is uh I didn't know I didn't know much
of the work uh because I was like I I
didn't either I didn't know who who
right well I saw I saw I think it was on
Instagram and I saw something about it
and then I quickly went on to Google to
be like oh who is this and I was like oh
okay maybe I've seen his work because
he's a dancer but it's not someone that
I um
message
um earlier and Brett I guess his office
was kind of cross the way right yeah
because Brett used to work yeah and um
uh he gave a a great message I I didn't
know if you knew much but I I I didn't
watch Ellen no really watched Ellen Show
I mean it's some clips and stuff and it
was probably Brett mizellis that made a
lot of those clips right that I actually
watched but I I've never watched the
show my mom's a great fan of Ellen she
she watches Ellen launch she loves
Ellen's show and I didn't get a chance
to talk to her this morning about this
but um but um it's such a sad State
um right where someone who seems so
happy and so alive and
um so talented uh on the inside
um is struggling uh and and would take
their own life so now again I just want
to remind everybody
as we go through the day that just
because someone's smiling doesn't mean
they're not frowning on the inside so
have some have some um decency and you
know look at someone as a human and I
think that's what we lack a lot these
days yeah I think I think the way
people's Humanity there there is a lot
of that you know even on obviously the
political side you don't know
you don't know someone's life and you
know what they're going through
um
uh it is unfortunate that you know
certain people will try to
to pull out or attack you know someone
going through something
um as as a as opposed to having empathy
and understanding like oh this person is
having a difficult time in their life
right now
um
and
and knowing that when people go through
those things or after right after this
unfortunate event of him taking his own
life now looking back and being like
okay maybe this is a moment to like
reach out to people maybe this is a
moment to like really understand what's
going on if this moment to do is
self-assessment see how I'm doing right
my own mental health I know like anyone
that is following politics it can be a
very
even in the last couple months I've
actually
um tried to form a habit where and I
don't know if the audience has noticed
this but I don't tweet a lot
um on the weekends and I don't tweet a
lot in the evenings I try to stay away I
try to read what's happening right I try
to stay away and unfortunately I don't I
ignore my DMs sometimes on purpose
because of that just for my own mental
health that I need I need time away and
inside my own space not inside uh
someone else's space if that makes sense
and maybe that does maybe that doesn't
um but I agree you get you got to take a
break from whatever troubles you and
find happiness somewhere
um and and let people know let people
know when you're struggling it did you
don't have to smile on the outside all
the time it reminds me a lot
um this case this morning of uh twitch
again again I don't know his work very
well but it reminds me a lot of Robin
Williams where you know he was so Lively
and there was so much life out you know
on the outside and he would smile and he
was joking and make people laugh and he
would entertain people and he was a gift
to other people and yet on the inside it
was not that way so
um just remember that when you see when
you see people out and about
um that you know take that in
consideration we got a lot of stuff to
round up today I've got
oh man I've got a video to show you Gabe
Sanchez that Donald Trump posted oh I
was just gonna send that one too it is
cringe as [ __ ] and I it is such a
[ __ ] joke I can't even believe this
thing is real and I can't even believe
that he posted it but we are gonna go
watch this video so audience uh stick
around for the shitless Roundup because
we are about to round up all the Tweety
tweets and trendy Trend start the
countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Trends some people in the um the chant
there is saying Tony how do you not know
what skirt steak is listen I grew up on
Casey strips sirloin rib eye and we did
a lot of pork steak that's good we we
ate a lot of poor pork chops pork steaks
you know that sort of thing so I'm a
farmer I don't do pork chops that often
anymore it's just like not something
that's like
on top of mind you know like a pork I
don't know I don't know like if I'm in a
restaurant sometimes I'll get it like if
it's available you know like maybe I'll
get it once in a while but like it's not
something I actively go to the grocery
store and say oh you know what I want
this week pork chops it's just like yeah
but the pork steak man I you know I'm a
chop fan a pork steak if you do it right
if you marinate it right you put it on
the on the grill
now baby I I can I can Grill some pork
steak I can Grill something I don't even
know Monster Forks if I've ever had a
pork steak what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you okay so see we're at a crossroad
here yeah
um once you have skirt steak then we'll
talk okay well we'll do that we'll do
that we'll do that
oh
speaking of pork brains holy [ __ ] did
you see this video I started watching a
halfway through and then I was like nope
I don't want to ruin it I gotta bring it
up on the show this is this is insanity
so he posted I don't know when did he
post this yesterday or today
did he make this what's the [ __ ]
story behind this I just watched the
video no I I just came across uh well
there's another video I haven't even
watched it yet but I guess send that one
to me which one's that it was Nick
Fuentes went on oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
right hey I'm gonna play that one yeah
definitely I'm definitely gonna play the
next which is interesting because now I
have to I feel like I might have to add
this to the what was that I don't know
are you almost done with it or well I'm
trying I started I went on every time
you do one of these [ __ ]
someone else said something you're like
God damn it it was going to my ending
was with Marjorie Taylor green okay it
was with her ending of like if we ran
the [ __ ] January 6th Insurrection all
that [ __ ] so that's how it ends but we
would actually committed a coup right I
filmed it because I film it at this desk
I put the green screen up and I film it
at this desk hey you're ruin it for
everybody you're like whoa you're nice
[Laughter]
somebody once said uh oh look Gabe's
back in his prison cell
I I come out I come out from my prison
cell but anyway you know we we worked we
worked hard on that background you went
you went through several versions I I
went through a lot and you sent that one
um because I remember when you were when
we were working on what was that trying
to figure out what what that was going
to be yeah you were talking about what
was that right what what is it what was
that and and and you sent that one I'm
like that's the one and then you put the
the silhouette of the window on it yeah
yeah was that on it or did you put that
on I don't know it was another it was
from another thing that I had yeah yeah
so you put the silhouette I'm like yep
that makes it look real do that one that
was the one so that's that's how that's
how you ended up because there was a lot
a lot of people are like oh you just do
that together we you worked
so this is what happened so I have a uh
I had an alarm that was set yesterday
and it went off at 9 00 pm and I was
filming and I got like I want to say if
I had like 10 more minutes I would have
finished everything the alarm goes off
and I was like oh
dismiss
and I have a program on my an app on my
phone that I run it on
and
in my mind did it close the app no in my
mind I was like oh dismiss the alarm
right
and I was like okay [ __ ] camera no no
no no what happened was the alarm
whenever some whenever another activity
like that comes in it'll stop the the
because you're filming it from your
iPhone right right and that's that's the
other that's the other trick that people
know
all from my phone I know but so
basically what happened was the alarm
went off and when anything like that
comes in like another application then I
have to be like oh okay it's it closes
like it it stops recording and then it
says what do you want to do copy paste
it uh save it send it whatever you want
to do and in my mind I said okay cool
dismiss and I was like hopefully I
didn't [ __ ] with anything
and I hit I hit save right because it
was like what do you want to do I hit
save and there's like
loading and it's like do not close the
app and I was like [ __ ] okay fine so
there's like going going going going is
it still going this morning yeah I would
have probably still been like so I
waited for like five minutes I was like
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] and I was like all
right how much how much filming did you
do how many minutes the whole thing the
whole like pretty much the whole thing I
probably had like another 20 minutes so
now I gotta redo the thing later today
this is this is not the first time this
has happened that you've re-recorded
this so basically it's like if anyone's
watching this please watch the video
when it comes out I hope it's not
irrelevant anymore
two weeks later it's still oh my God God
damn the [ __ ] you go through to provide
content
um in in a particular way and that's
just how we did that that's why I see
that's why I'm I'm in the zone here
because I don't like you know me and I
like all the fanciness let's just let's
turn the [ __ ] microphone on and let's
rip it let's just do it that way and a
lot of people I wonder you know maybe
wonder how I prep but you can just go to
my Twitter page and figure out how I
pray I just retweet the [ __ ] and that's
what we're going to talk about today on
the show that's how I produce this [ __ ]
and I just go the first 30 minutes of
the show like today I was like oh [ __ ] I
got five minutes to figure out what the
hell I'm gonna talk about
then that's that's what came out that's
what came out so that's how it goes
um
let's talk about this video and let's
see if we can figure out why where this
[ __ ] thing came from did he did he
have this made did someone make this and
he's like oh this is great I'll repost
it because it's cringe as [ __ ] yeah
let's watch let's watch Superhero Trump
here whatever those is
um he he'd post this video on Broad
Social and says in all caps America
needs a superhero
it's it's already getting weird what
other a major announcement other than uh
uh a VP but that's why it has to be
planned right yeah isn't that what isn't
that what you drive from this it's like
he had he had to have had someone make
this for him because you're gonna see in
the video that they talk about a major
announcement unless you don't think he
you don't think he found the video and
then they're like oh this is good and
they're like well just say there's a
major announcement yeah yeah
let's watch this it's a [ __ ] what's
such a [ __ ] joke let's watch America
needs a superhero
guys
[Music]
Tuesday Thursday December 15th so
tomorrow I gotta wait a whole day for
this
so so tomorrow there's gonna be an
announcement I I don't know what it's
supposed to be maybe that he's switching
diaper brands or something I have no
idea what like you said what possibly
could be an announcement at this point I
really do wonder what he could announce
I mean what would be a major
announcement I do here let me here let
me roll back the let me look at the text
messages that Don Jr has been sending me
oh yeah yeah there you go that'll give
you some insight because they definitely
would would be planting seeds inside the
grift machines so on Monday I got uh
president Trump I asked my team to make
this special link for you your offer is
expiring soon so he's clearly wanted
money uh don Jr they want money again
are you kidding me crazy Don Jr do you
want a trip to Mar-A-Lago you may even
you okay hold on wait he's pimping he's
pimping a a vacation tomorrow Lago or is
this like this is done so from Don Jr do
you want a trip to Mar-A-Lago question
mark exclamation you may even meet my
father Donald J Trump so you can come to
Mar-A-Lago maybe you'll meet my dad
maybe you won't we'll see
uh and then another one says press Trump
knows you're a top supporter I've never
donated uh so he's giving you are you
really a top supporter that's surprising
Gabe Sanchez yeah with uh with all the
[ __ ] hate in my heart
um wants to give you one of our 2022
Trump Christmas ornament
uh you have one hour uh I I'm sure I
could click on the link in any time I
can actually you could still get more
[ __ ] ornaments uh we asked president
Trump to give you one more chance 9x
impact extended one hour they're really
desperate they do that a lot that impact
thing right almost every email they're
like 12 1200 12 10 10 impact uh this is
another one unclaimed 2023 Trump
calendar maybe that's the announcement
maybe that's the announcement one
message or one message from Donald J
Trump response requested take the 2024
Trump agenda survey today which every
time they ask for a survey you have to
donate to submit an answer which is
crazy so you're not actually taking it
so the only people here's the thing the
only people that answer the thing are
the people that don't are going to be
incredibly skewed one way no I mean
obviously there's a there's a barrier
yeah there's a barrier which is fine but
at the same time you're like the only
people who are going to be answering are
gonna be favorably so they're all going
to be 100 yeah
have you ever have you ever gave just a
dollar to try to take the survey to see
what it says I don't know uh press Trump
to fakeness the fake news is out of
control I need you to take the media
accountability survey again it asks for
money every time you give an answer it
asks for money but there was one there
was oh Don Jr was asking uh on Sunday he
said will you become oh a trump campaign
Cabinet member my father needs a
response in five minutes to finalize oh
well [ __ ] five minutes better get on it
huh yeah so you have to pay to become a
[ __ ] a member of the cabinet I'm sure
you do everything you do everything
uh is always a is a paid survey you
think that's why we haven't had the big
Kool-Aid moment in this country yet is
because they'd actually have to pay for
the Kool-Aid oh yeah yeah that's
probably what it is like I got the
Kool-Aid and they're like great and he's
like all right now I'm gonna charge you
for the cups right 100 bucks but we'll
10 exit if yeah
12th power make the Kool-Aid even more
more poisonous
oh God these [ __ ] Griffin
[ __ ] I want to go back to this
uh the screenshot here though of course
the major announcement is just going to
be tomorrow and I'm sure it's just gonna
be you know a barn burner of an
announcement but here's this [ __ ]
thing here this okay so number one he's
posing in front of Trump Tower which
he's gonna lose yeah I was just gonna
say I don't know if anyone knows this
Trump Tower is not going to be Trump
Tower for very much longer Tish James is
going to make sure of that yeah um she's
gonna bury Trump Tower there's those
also what is with this [ __ ]
Fascination to put Trump's head on an
incredibly like ripped body you got
[ __ ] Stallone he's like oh this is
Trumbo and then you got this guy who's
[ __ ] Trump trump man yeah but these
are these are [ __ ] that run
around in big ass trucks with big ass
tires big huge 20 flags with a set of
[ __ ] you know plastic nuts hanging
from the back of it yeah I mean to show
their manliness you really don't think
that this appeals to that [ __ ] no no
no totally I mean like it's all
obviously it's all projection right they
watch these they watch these uh movies
and videos and they see people [ __ ]
We're Men
it's totally cool if I [ __ ] give him
a hand job you know like that saying
that about Trump right these people
would be like it's okay if I give Trump
a hand job it's like hey man you know
you do you you are who you are feel how
you want to feel no judgment
I guarantee if he sold people a butt
plug that said Trump on it they would
Trump 2024. they would guaranteed those
people would use it they would buy it
they would use pictures on social and
they'd be like check me out and on the
bottom it said uh I don't know you're
fired or something like that all right
you're fired on the butt plug I don't
know that sounds about right
um speaking of um
butt plugs so yeah I have not I have not
washed this yet so I don't know what
what they say okay so so this this is
Nick Fuentes for anyone who doesn't know
now of course we've been pointing out
Nick Fuentes for a long time yeah and
I've been we've been saying for a long
time that he is the coordinator of their
messaging he's the pushing of their
messaging and the Republican party and
it's been no more clear in the last
several weeks and that is true because
they're trying desperately to run away
from him now and they can't like they're
tied to him well I think I think the
reason is because
uh they went just like Roe v Wade in the
sense that they overstepped their they
like went a little too far too quick
right they were like oh we're gonna take
it away and everyone's like what do you
mean they jumped in the Hitler pool way
too fast yeah they jumped the Nazi shark
we'll say and in this sense by bringing
on Kanye on these different programs
whether it's Gavin McInnis you've got uh
uh yeah yeah Alex Jones Tim Poole right
and Infowars here the show that uh Nick
Fuentes is on here is Infowars now this
is after the the con yeah
right right because apparently Nick
Fuentes and Alex Jones we're gonna we're
gonna debate this out well because what
happened was they went on to this is
this is the timeline sorry so Alex Jones
has them on Kanye's like I love Hitler I
love Putin you know uh Nick Fuentes or
rather Nick Fuentes is like I really
like Putin and I support him and
Connie's like yeah me too
and really weird [ __ ] yeah it was weird
so that that'll happen a lot of people
were like oh [ __ ] this is too much too
quick right Jim Jordan was like delete
that tweet right then not Donald Trump
though he didn't he was no no no no no
again he has not condemned Kanye West or
Nick Fuentes
right and he likes them he likes how
noisy they are they go they go on the
show and then afterward everyone's like
whoa uh that's a little too much Nick
Fuentes after the fact was like I think
people are just like misinterpreting the
appearance on the show and what really
went down right it's like no yeah the
words I love Hitler it yeah you can't
you know somebody you need context and
then they go on to Gavin McKinney's show
and he again doubles down even he was
yeah even I mean you know you [ __ ] up
when Gavin McInnis and Alex Jones say
cooling with the Nazi talk right and
then what happened was well not the Nazi
talk they just don't want you to be
overtly for Hitler exactly they don't
want you to stay quiet part out loud
yeah right they're fine with
anti-Semitism we saw that but once you
start saying Hitler and Nazi and you
love them and all this [ __ ] you got
they're like oh that's too quick right
too quick people are really going to
know where anti-semites when you see
that kind of stuff so then because what
here let me I'll sh I'll send you this
video I think this is the one
uh this is what this is what preceded
this moment right here so after after
this led up too yeah after this after
they went on the show people were like
oh my God how could he have mine you
know he said all this stuff even Alex
Jones again during the show was trying
to like course correct and be like not
so much and Kanye was like nope I love
Hitler this looks like it's Stephen
Crowder's [ __ ] right so he went on to
Stephen Crowder's show because they were
even trying to be like oh we're not we
don't because like Kanye's the greatest
ever and you know they were all in favor
of Kanye until he started you know
saying he loves Hitler then like whoa
[ __ ] and also to hear to hear Alex
Jones's
excuse for Nick Fuentes is even funnier
is it because the demons hate Hitler is
that why yeah we'll say we'll say it's
the demons
this should be interesting what's is
this is this Alex Jones's explanation of
it this is uh let me just make sure hold
on one sec
I think that's what this is yeah yeah
this is it this is the one okay okay
listen I didn't know that Nick Fuentes
was really a Nazi lover I got him on
over the years three or four times
whenever he was being debanked or
censored like 12 to 15 times rice so I
think this this whole thing was a real
coming out uh and I'll be honest with
you uh especially with the point test
thing and I'll still have point this on
I believe in the First Amendment uh but
there's a real creepy factor with this
Hitler stuff oh [ __ ] they got caught
didn't they they got caught because like
well he said it's homoerotic is the way
that Alice Jones describes their Hitler
like Fascination well and that's and
that's what they're trying to do is
trying to make it trying to make it to
where the simps will ease up on the
Hitler talk yeah because the samps were
really all about it they were like you
goddamn right Connie I mean dude you
post anything I'd post anything on
[ __ ] uh Twitter about Kanye or or
Nazis or anything and they were in my
[ __ ] can three I didn't know who the
[ __ ] they were just some kind of [ __ ]
uh Nazi scent bot and and it's always
the same like when you find one of these
these [ __ ] these Nazi Bots if you go
to their likes right go to their account
go to the likes and go down they're like
an Elon they're liking [ __ ] Benny
Johnson they love them some some uh uh
uh uh what the woods what's his name uh
James Woods James Woods they love that
guy the guy who was upset he couldn't
share uh they're buying his dick pics
Jack prostate they love him I mean you
know you can tell who these [ __ ]
people are right and the idea that Alex
Jones didn't know that Nick Fuentes was
a [ __ ] Nazi you are a dumb son of a
[ __ ] it didn't take more than one
goddamn search to figure out that this
that this [ __ ] idiot has been talking
about Holocaust denying and talking
about how he loves Hitler Jesus Christ
he stood up at the America First pack or
whatever the hell it was where he was
across the street from CPAC you remember
this they tried to get oh that was the
one in Texas they [ __ ] kicked him out
Margaret Taylor green went and spoke at
this no no that was a different one oh
okay well there was two separate ones
two different Nazi rallies two different
Nazi rallies okay there was one in
Dallas where he was like this is gonna
be the most anti-Semitic misogynistic he
was standing outside CPAC saying right
yeah yeah and they were trying to win
they wouldn't let it into Sheraton or
the Marriott across the street and then
there's a different one which is the one
that was in February with Margarita
green right and and and Nick Fuentes
even says on stage there's there's
[ __ ] video of it man he's talking
about Putin and people compare Putin to
Hitler and like well we love we love
Putin give a round of applause for
Russia and they're you know a bunch of
these [ __ ] trumped up white dudes are
you know cheering cheering on Russia's
Hitler Putin I mean that their words not
mine so the idea that Alex Jones did not
know I mean he really has he's had him
he's Adam I think the count is like 12
to 15 times he's had him on the show
before right so like I've only had him
like a handful of times like four times
I have no idea and also the fact if
you're gonna bring someone on you can't
tell me that you don't know who that
person is that's the same dumb excuse
that Marjorie Taylor green was like I
didn't know who he was I was trying to
talk to his audience you made a bunch of
Nazis yeah you knew dude when they
cheered you one you were so [ __ ]
giddy you were like oh yes I [ __ ]
love Hitler and uh that's the craziest
part about the whole uh Marjorie Taylor
green excuse for speaking at the Nazi
rally she's like I just wanted to lend
an ear to his audience they're young and
I'm like yeah but they're listening to
him and they're Nazis because they're
listening to him right so you're you're
going to go
to Nazis in support of you what the [ __ ]
are you in the in the what was that that
I'm working on I don't even I don't even
sh like I I had that because it was from
Alex Costa from CBS I have that clip
where they're talking he's like well
she's he's a he's a white supremacist
like he's away Bob Costa
where he's asking he's asking her and I
think she was leaving CPAC yeah when
when she was on her way out and he
stopped her and she actually stopped and
tried to engage to try to backpedal once
she realized maybe I shouldn't have went
to the Nazi yeah she's like I'm not bad
about it right she said in the interview
she's like I'm not now she is yeah
she was like I'm not pro Putin I don't
know who this guy was like no you did
know who the guy was it literally
happened the same the same group is the
[ __ ] movement that you just went on a
summer tour America First this guy
invented invented the modern America
first movement just where this all comes
from just like the idea that Trump
didn't know who he was you're gonna tell
me that the guy who has AF America First
his group
you you don't know who that guy is
especially since it shares the same
values with Margie Taylor green right
get the [ __ ] out of here so what was
that I don't even show that clip because
I'm like no dude she was [ __ ] excited
to be in a rebel enough but but it's
Gabe it's the same thing yeah when she
went this weekend to the New York
Republican elite club and she spoke at
the the elitist group where she had on
the you know the thousands of dollar
gown and the beads and and she spoke
against the political prisoners right
that were January 6th she was like
they're losers they didn't win we would
have wanted we planned it they're losers
but then she'll leave there and go back
to wherever
of course and she'll and she'll say
she'll say Well they're political
prisoners and they're being held captive
because of politics and all this
nonsense the exact opposite [ __ ] they
don't actually believe in any of this
stuff yeah no it's all to push their
fascist agenda speaking of fascist
agenda um now this is a clip from Nick
Fuentes coming back on Alex Jones's show
is that right yeah this is from yeah I
believe this is last night yesterday or
yesterday yeah and it's only 35 seconds
long but it doesn't take long to sniff
out a Nazi it really doesn't 20 30
seconds is just enough time let's listen
it's about saying we need to call out
the Jewish media and and he's been
saying look we don't care about your
honestly we don't care about your
grandmother that died in the Holocaust
I'm sorry that's always what they come
with it's always the guilt trip it's the
emotional propaganda I know that sounds
callous I know that sounds insensitive
but it's no different than any of this
other racial grievance politics over
slavery or over colonization or genocide
I see no difference between AOC calling
us colonizers and these Jewish groups
calling us Holocaust deniers it's the
same weaponization of racial grievance
to to brow beat us into submission
oh they're such victims Gabe Sanchez oh
it's almost it's almost as if they know
that these these views are vile and
disgusting yeah and it's really
ridiculous that you're like they know
exactly what they're saying they know
what they mean when they say it you know
the idea that
that
he's going to come off and be like it's
the same way that people call colonizers
it's it's not uh I mean it really isn't
it it's two different things right but
what he's trying to do and here's what
he's trying to do in his messaging and
this is really important because
now that Nick Fuentes and Kanye West
know how toxic their talk is and how how
Amplified their messaging is they're
trying to pack it into a different box
right right and what they're trying to
do is divert your attention from them
saying Hitler's great to AOC saying
Hitler's bad right like that's that's
what they're trying to do so they're
trying to change the message of trying
to change the narrative and that we as
the people now especially on this show
We're not gonna allow them to [ __ ] do
that [ __ ] hails to the middle We're not
gonna allow them do that but you you out
there talking to people and conversing
with people about these [ __ ] [ __ ]
just being outright Nazis and saying the
quiet part out loud you you can make
sure the messaging is not well AOC says
this well who gives a [ __ ] what AOC says
she's who cares if she calls people
colonizers right that what the [ __ ] does
that have to do with Kanye West and Nick
went says going any dinner with the
presumptive nominee at this point of the
Republican party and they're spewing
that they love Hitler and Hitler into
this guy's brain and he's inviting and
he won't condemn them come on that's the
[ __ ] that that's the point
it ain't got nothing to do with the word
colonizer right yeah and I mean like
because I mean really at the end of the
day what it is is they're trying to say
okay what is our equivalent right what
do we get triggered by what do we
believe that never really happened and
what makes us sad right exactly and it's
like when a white man is oppressed and
we're not and the idea that it's like uh
there's a big difference between Sign
Language by saying like look you're
you're rejecting you're denying that
this event like where did six million
Jewish people go in the world they
didn't just [ __ ] poof Into Thin Air
they were they were killed it was a
genocide right it is the Holocaust
denying that is way different than you
getting butt hurt because somebody said
hey a bunch of European people came over
to this land and took it
however means by whatever means murder
murder
sometimes right there you're not are you
it's and then the other thing too is
like they're not denying that there was
a genocide here in this country right
they're being like oh well we came over
so nice but there was right there was a
fight and but again that's that's what
they want right is they want us to fight
out what AOC says about the colonization
of the Americas here from white people
they want that fight because their side
will love that fight and it is it has
nothing to do with Hitler right that's
the whole point and that's what I'm
that's what I want to to focus on with
the audience is that we can't let them
run away from this Hitler thing because
right folks they know they made a huge
mistake they thought it was a great idea
they were like oh my God this is going
to be fantastic Elon now owns Twitter
this is gonna blow up we're really we're
really we're really gonna see how many
people believe this stuff and they got a
huge huge pushback yeah again like I
said it's it's Roe v Wade all over again
they really thought they had this [ __ ]
in the back they thought they could say
change the rules they could do this do
that but it turns out that there's an
overwhelming majority and that the only
people that support them is a minority
it's a bigoted group of people who want
to suppress another group of people
right it's a sliver of white people who
feel oppressed because oh my God
everyone's getting their voice heard God
forbid it's the land of the free and
there's equal opportunity and every
person's made equal oh my God
so when you see them
they say okay great we're going to throw
him on and he's going to say this thing
and then oh my God okay [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
this okay uh a board of board abort like
that's the problem like okay that's
actually when they are in favor of
abortion yeah well right when they when
they want to abort the whole Hitler
message well but again back to Roe v
Wade the problem is
well not our problem it's their problem
and we should point it out and keep
hammering this message is that they let
that quiet part out of the bag right and
that's really the hard part for them
about the quiet part outlet that's why
I'm excited that DeSantis has come up in
the polls I'm I'm super excited that
DeSantis that poll is probably all
[ __ ] it's probably just [ __ ]
nonsense it's probably a garbage Bowl
but it doesn't matter it's going to live
inside Trump's head and Trump is going
to go on the offensive attack to
DeSantis and we as as as pro-democracy
people should take every single word and
every single moment and politicize the
absolute [ __ ] out of that and draw
wedges because they can't stop with the
dumb ideas they can't they can't quit
have you seen this clip of Kevin
McCarthy talking about the order this
this is the dumbest [ __ ] I there's a
lot of dumb ideas they've had especially
this [ __ ] guy Kevin McCarthy he is a
dumb son of a [ __ ] he is and keep in
mind Kevin McCarthy right now is
struggling to get all the votes he needs
yeah
Trump do you think he's gonna get there
I don't know it's day to day with me I'm
like maybe uh no no I honestly think
this is actually one of the things you
can't manage it I don't yeah I don't
think he can manage to get to 218
because he can't be he can't beat Trump
enough and he can't be not you know with
Trump and I think that's the thing
they're trying to manage right now is
because Jack Smith man is not [ __ ]
around and and that special counsel is
going to come down hard not just on
Trump but it looks like on on others
State officials the state elector scheme
these members of [ __ ] Congress it's
possible that they're going to come down
on them and they're they're a little
[ __ ] terrified of that so they're not
sure how to manage that but listen to
yesterday I'm gonna play the clip of
Lauren bobert she had a really dumb idea
yesterday you might have seen this
everywhere she was saying in Peach and
Peach the um Department of Homeland
Security uh ahead because they're
seizing fentanyl at the border
to impeach him because he's seizing
fentanyl this is [ __ ] dumb he's doing
his job
and he's gonna be impeached for his job
but here is even a dumber idea about the
Border this is the dumbest [ __ ] idea
I've ever heard of listen to this the
difference that's going to happen in 20
days from now on January 3rd I will move
hearings to the border so these
committees in Congress in Washington
don't hold these hearings here it'll be
at the border so the Democrats can no
longer avoid the situation I'm Gonna
Learn firsthand what's going on in the
American public they're going to waste
taxpayer money this is the stupidest
[ __ ] thing I've ever heard of in my
life that that they're gonna go down and
set up tables I don't know I don't know
let me get this straight they're gonna
go down to the border to put on camera
uh like uh whatever's happening right
now that's going on whether it's uh
migrants or it's drugs they're gonna put
it on full display
so they're gonna they're gonna hold on
Kevin McCarthy is suggesting that now
when it comes to budgetary restraints we
don't we don't try to tighten things up
we say you know what we will pay for the
lodging and transportation and the
logistics of somebody multiple people on
this committee and people who have to
show up to testify and the Press like
this is these dumbest [ __ ] this is
the dumbest [ __ ] thing I've ever
heard of in my life okay folks let me
tell you something
that if you just use you know a couple
brain cells
it would you would realize this policy
makers do not have to go hold hearings
about facts that they've gathered at the
place where they gathered the facts that
is not they don't hold uh criminal
trials at the crime scene this is really
[ __ ] stupid this is the dumbest thing
I've ever heard in my life and the only
thing he's trying to do here is to
trying to get he's trying to get the
racist bigoted [ __ ] members in in his
in his caucus to vote for him that is
all he's trying to do here this is the
stupidest [ __ ] idea I've ever heard
of in my life it honestly might be the
only time that somebody like Ted Cruz
actually is in the state that he
represents that doesn't flee right well
the only time he's ever been down in
Texas other than when he was trying to
come passing out I was able to drop it
off my my two daughters and I was like
okay uh is the idea that he was there
for when they're at the border and
they're like we're gonna we're going to
find out what's going at the border
meanwhile you got the [ __ ] coyotes
like literal the people that are helping
migrants get across the border [ __ ]
mocking them across the Rio Grande which
is hilarious right
um and you had that you think they knew
who he was when they were mocking him oh
yeah uh I guarantee I guarantee they're
like look it's Ted Cruz yeah they're
like oh look look at this little cuck uh
they saw him they saw the little
wolverine beard wannabe you know
basketball dribbling you know Cancun
fleeing like that's they knew exactly
who he was
they also knew who the Lindsey Graham
was who was also funny to be there they
were in the Border policy yeah Amanda
Amanda points had a good thing here this
is this is what Republicans don't want
to admit that the only difference and
really it is the key difference between
uh what the Trump administration's
policy was and what the Biden
administration's policy is is the only
difference in the Border policy is that
Biden doesn't put babies in cages and
separate families that's the only
difference and a lot of people
um harp on sending people back that's a
little bit of the other difference and I
think that's what Amanda's saying here
in separate families is they're not
sending people who come here
um that can be sent back to Mexico are
sent back that is that was a trump
Administration policy Biden has filed
that policy now they're more Humane
about it they actually you know try to
try to be Humane about it right as
Amanda's pointing out but that is the
biggest difference so again even more
reason why it's such such a dumb idea
for Kevin McCarthy to set up a hearing
at the border so Democrats can point
that [ __ ] out like what a [ __ ]
bonehead like this is the dumbest idea
number one it's going to be a disaster
for them because oh yeah like you were
saying any of these little because they
go down there about every week and a
half right and the Republicans have a
little um you know photo op at the
border right because they gotta be look
like they still support Trump's wall or
some [ __ ] that's fallen down behind him
yeah um you know so they do this every
week and a half so now he's like okay
well we'll hold hearings there that'll
get me another four votes in the house
and it'll get Andy Biggs off my ass
because here's the uh Andy Biggs was at
the uh press conference and I actually
think it was kind of his press
conference where Lauren bobert let me
see if I can find this I didn't retweet
this [ __ ]
um but yeah he's I mean he's struggling
to get the 218 that he needs to get in a
majority you know leadership position
and right now it's the same reason why
he won't call out Trump because there
are people in the in the party that
still
sit with Trump and they believe in
trumpism so the only thing he says is
like well I I believe he's condemned it
he's done it four times he hasn't said
[ __ ] oh well nobody should be affiliated
with Nick Fuentes right and like even if
you look there's emails that were sent
after this happened there's a political
article that talks about the emails that
were sent within the RNC and people are
like dude he needs to say something
Trump needs to say something and then
some people are like he's not going to
yeah no I mean they were talking about
Richard Spencer who's a Nazi to throw
all this [ __ ] but the reason why he
won't say anything against Nick Fuentes
is because Trump knows who Nick Fuentes
is and understands that Nick Fuentes
speaks to the [ __ ] Nazis who support
him and listen it is not easy and and
and I I want to paint a picture for the
audience here Jared Kushner is a Jewish
person
Ivanka converted to Judaism her children
are are Jewish children they [ __ ]
hate that they [ __ ] hate that about
Trump yeah they [ __ ] hate that
because they're so [ __ ] bigoted in
their ways and he has to manage that
that is something that he has to manage
with the Nazis and the white
supremacists I don't know if you're
aware of that but that is a that is a
difficult [ __ ] water to tread for
Trump and he understands that he knows
and Richard Spencer who is not you know
who's no longer a Trumper but still is a
Nazi right uh well he I mean once I mean
it's hard to go back right right yeah
yeah I mean like he was doing an
interview I think we maybe have played
it on the show he's basically talking
against Trump yeah he was like look he
can't well he was he wasn't talking
against Trump in the sense of uh it was
last week because we played the video of
him getting punched in the face oh well
yeah but he was saying he's like I have
as context not as well yeah yeah he was
like yeah he was like uh I I haven't
been
um
a trump supporter for a trump supporter
for like five years or so so he might
not like me but he will not call them
out because he knows who Butters his
bread that's right
that's one that's and that's and really
and Spencer's defense if you want to say
that he's correct on that he's like
Trump won't do it is because Trump
understands where his support comes from
he knows where the base of his support
comes from it comes from bigoted white
supremacists like this okay
so I'm thinking here right and I'm again
I I'm almost regretting my statements
um that Kevin McCarthy just said the
dumbest thing ever about the borderline
it's hard to beat Lauren bober and I'll
tell you even though I even though I
know this video exists and I watched it
I just I'm struggling Gabe Sanchez to
really figure out which which one is
dumber a dumber idea listen listen to
this idea and see what you think about
this one see if this one you know suits
your fancy for dumbest of the week
Majorca says watch more than 14 000
pounds of fentanyl was seized and okay
so so she said she said what she said
under my orcas which he's the Department
of Homeland Security uh secretary right
yeah he's responsible for you know she
she just said that he seized 1500 pounds
isn't that his job kinda I mean in
theory you would expect the Department
of Homeland Security had to at least
least be doing a good enough job that
the Department of Homeland Security like
the the you know the the beer the
biocracy underneath them was able to
seize giving them the tools the
opportunity you know giving them
everything they needed to seize drugs at
the border and that isn't that the point
it's almost yeah like their whole well
not their whole job but the big part of
their job is controlling the border and
the drugs that come through it and if
they were able to stop 1500 pounds is
what she just said and he seized it
which means they got it
and they stopped it from going across
the border into those little suburbs and
those little kids that all the
Republicans want to talk about
you would surely that she would be
supportive surely this means she
supports him right right okay well let's
listen in fiscal year 2022 at our
Southern border
that is an all-time record high
okay so the reason why she's saying this
is this is a argument on why he should
be impeached
oh it's 14 000 pounds fourteen thousand
and fourteen hundred fifty I thought you
said 1500
all right we can let's do it again let's
go back maybe Orca says watch more than
14 000 pounds no she said 14. okay I
don't know I heard 15 14 000. holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
I don't know if anyone knows how much 14
000 pounds of fentanyl fentanyl are
little bitty [ __ ] pills right like
they're well I mean where the size of uh
uh you know a normal sized aspirin I've
never taken Fitness what the [ __ ] man
that's crazy they called it you know on
Skittles they were they claimed it was
going to be in all the Halloween candy
yeah for free they were going to bring
it across yeah the Border well no what
no even better than that brown people
were gonna come to this country buy
houses and neighborhoods right and then
ship ship the fentanyl into this country
and then give it out during Halloween to
somehow make the country less white I
it's [ __ ] it's bonus do they believe
that taking fennel turns you not white
no no no they were gonna kill white
children oh god listen listen do you
think do you think a bunch of non-white
children go to Halloween Gabe Sanchez
that's not I mean in their little Minds
because you got listen this I'm dead
serious about this
people who live in rural white areas
have this idea again I grew up in a
white town all white there were not many
people of color so when we were being
racist because I grew up in that
environment there was no one to be
racist against yeah we were all it was
all a bunch of crackers there was no
[ __ ] people of color around
to be racist against now we were racist
as [ __ ] that's the institution but
that's the [ __ ] narrative that these
white towns get because you gotta
remember
like that when Walter or the good liars
would play these videos at Trump browse
you'd be like yeah they're coming over
here and they're gonna poison our
children they mean white children here's
what they here's here's the [ __ ] idea
they have in their head is it brown
people are gonna cross the border
they're gonna somehow buy or rent houses
in white areas and they're gonna pass
out Fentanyl and Fentanyl is deadly
remember if you just look at it Gabe
Sanchez if you just get a glance of
fentanyl you'll die from a heart attack
immediately if you give it yeah if you
look at the wrong way boom right done
yeah you did that yeah that's the thing
that's the thing man that's the whole
that's that was the whole that's what
they were and the media was buying at
Hook Line Seeker the media is like I
mean [ __ ] non-stop the media was like
oh is fentanyl gonna be in Halloween
candy and what the media didn't even
understand is that white people are
sitting there watching going goddamn
right there is brown people coming
across the border they're gonna buy
houses I mean the government's going to
give them houses and then they're going
to feed the fentanyl to the white kids
because that's the only kids in their
neighborhood there are no in some of
these [ __ ] rural white towns there
are no people of color they're all white
it's all white
it the idea that
that's the reality that's what they were
trying to spin it's like I never want to
hit my head into the wall because the
idea that they're like oh yeah people
people who are looking for an
opportunity because they're trying to
seek Asylum or or just a better life
want to come to this country and then
give other people drugs
for free
but that but but again that's that's the
point is yeah you got to have because if
you're going to give it for free because
that was the thing that you're like what
the [ __ ] why would someone why would a
drug dealer give away their drugs for
free right that doesn't make any sense
but that's not what they were saying
right what they were saying is is that
they're going to give it away for the
motivation to make
it less white to make less white people
that's the replacement [ __ ] man I mean
that's the same idea that Trump was like
oh man that the word Caravan I created
the word Caravan that was the whole
thing that I create it's like first off
uh please look up the definition and
look at when Caravan was created but
also the idea that there was a caravan
of people coming in this country it's
the same idea oh they're stealing our
jobs really I'm pretty sure that that
job that they have in the field right
now where they're picking strawberries
and lettuce because that's the only
thing that they can get a job doing
let's say I'm pretty sure that you a
white person we're not doing [ __ ] and
you definitely wouldn't put yourself in
uh 16-hour days of hot Sun conditions
where you would pick those things in a
field I highly doubt it I highly because
that's because white people have too
much privilege and are too [ __ ] lazy
that's why
it's it's 100 why they think they
shouldn't have to work that hard right
it's their privilege not to have to have
to work so when you also when you look
at the states that are that are you know
the actual states that have the most
amount of welfare coming to them you're
like oh what are those others primarily
white oh got it okay yeah it's it's just
facts it's cold art facts and again this
is why I try to tell you the real and
raw facts because it's it is my
experience again I grew up in a town of
all white people all of them were white
they were all white and you say well how
in the hell would you be racist if
there's not anyone to be racist against
right that wasn't the point that wasn't
the point the point was is they wanted
to keep it all white and the way that
you keep it the whole town white is to
make sure no one can move in comfortably
that is what you do that is what you do
in these circumstances and in some parts
of Rural America and speaking of farming
and you know in Missouri there's a big
poultry business and a lot of these
rural areas have big turkey Farms
chicken farms and because it is such
dirty nasty work and really it's it's
unhealthy work to be quite honest with
you I don't know if you know anything
about poultry dust
um but it is very harmful to your
[ __ ] lungs and the reason why a lot
of people of color especially people of
Hispanic dissent move to these towns
because they're looking for that work
they'll they're willing to work hard to
support their families no matter where
they can do it
and so
inevitably over the last several decades
two or three decades in some of these
rural towns where these there's these
big uh processing plants Cargill is one
of the biggest
um and turkey processors and one of the
biggest turkey razors
and they they contract with Farmers for
their land for Barns and what happens is
is Cargill owns the [ __ ] turkeys
um the the farmer builds the buildings
and they get paid to raise the turkeys
there that's what happens and then
Cargill comes and picks them up and they
pay them for raising them in their barns
essentially and it's kind of a it's it's
a little different than that but that's
how it works but they eventually go to a
processing plant and I don't know if
you've watched videos of uh turkeys or
chickens being processed it is not a it
is it is not a pretty job and it's not
an easy work it's [ __ ] difficult
and it typically does not pay a lot of
money
and so what what happens is in in rural
areas is Hispanic people of Hispanic
descent move to those areas families
move to those areas and there there's a
lot of there's a lot of uh tropes and
stuff because these families move to
these areas for these jobs they're low
paying jobs they're they're disgusting
they're hard-working it's not easy it's
not easy work and I always I I always
got confused by this because I grew up
in White America where they talk about
family values and all this [ __ ] and how
families valuable and blah blah blah
Christianity and really honestly there's
no culture more steeped in Christianity
than and then a lot of Hispanic culture
and when they and when they would come
to these rural areas there would be a
lot of Hispanic families that would live
together in in a house so there was a
lot of people inside one house the main
reason why uh they don't weren't making
a lot of money right but the other
reason why and you know this well is
they have a very very very deep culture
in family I know that's very important
in their culture I mean we talked about
it with Texas Paul before right and I
know you can attest to that but white
people would demonize demonize this
culture of Christians who are who who
are a tight-knit family living in a
house all together I'm like what the
[ __ ] I just I was like and then they go
on TLC and watch the the 26 Kids and
Counting the [ __ ] Duggars those
[ __ ] groomers and they got 30 [ __ ]
kids living in one house like give me a
break you people are so brain dead well
it's it's because of the idea that
they're saving these children right
they're like oh you know right because
is that show that shows about them like
adopting fostering kids no they don't
know she had like 21 kids or so she is
okay now and I mean I mean there is the
white savior complex obviously that also
goes with that which is like oh
I'm sure if if you listen to their
argument or ask them a question they'd
be like well look if
if we didn't have those babies somebody
else would have and you're like that's
really [ __ ] weird that you would say
that like why do are you more deserving
to have a child in the other and that
also that's not how it [ __ ] works
that is not how it works and the other
thing too is I was just thinking about
this I guarantee
that let's say that Lauren bobert
impeaches the head of Department of
Homeland Security for doing this [ __ ]
job this is crazy [ __ ] all right so
let's play the let's play this thought
experiment out they get rid of this
person they put in someone who is a
Trumper right some guy who doesn't know
what he's doing Joe Biden nominated
someone who's a Trumper yeah but let's
say let's go with the dilution
it's all them right they impeach this
guy and then they put someone in and
whatever because they do know if they
are successful at impeaching him Joe
Biden doesn't understand the actual
process just like they go into what
stand with the word [ __ ] sees means
but let's play this thought experiment
out and they said you know what
uh he's gone and we put a new guy in we
put our guy in he's gonna do it he's
competent he knows exactly what to do
okay I'm like an idiot now here is
something that I believe would happen uh
14 000 goes down to uh a lower number
right much much lower or even zero let's
say it's just [ __ ] zero okay let's
say it's zero well I mean because if
seizing 14 000 pounds is bad then
seizing zero would be good if you
because what it shows is oh no drugs
ever came to the border which is insane
to think about so they go fourteen
thousand that's that is bad for seizing
but if they go oh look it's a big goose
egg zero if we didn't seize anything
then they were never anything to begin
with so that is their logic that is 100
there
you know their fingers in the ears I
know they're like if I don't I don't see
it I don't hear you know it's never
happened so if they're if they're there
were zero Drug C's that means that no
drugs ever came to the Border God that
is not how that works obviously but then
again it's Lauren bobert and she took
several tries to pass her GED and
possibly meet someone this is the
[ __ ]
um diluted reality that these boneheads
live in and again it's the same reality
that I was just telling you about in
White America I I grew up with it I I
know and me and Texas Paul have talked
about it that we grew up with it we've
seen it from hours perspective like what
in the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
that's not true at all and you know
it really is
kind of and we talked about this before
where um conservatives
and the Q Anon stuff and really
Republicans in general have been able to
attract more of the Hispanic Community
with with these narratives that they're
trying to spend which is what Lauren
bobert is trying to do because really
ultimately the debate here is not about
you know whether it's 14
000 pounds or 12 000 or 16 000 how many
pounds they're seizing at the board
the the discussion we need to have and
what they're trying to do is trying to
make hey all them brown people that
Caravan they're bad people they bring
fentanyl when that's not even the truth
the fentanyl that was being seized was
seized by from white people yeah
Americans going to Mexico getting the
finto bringing it back that that's where
it's being seized at the [ __ ] gate
not across the [ __ ] wall and even if
and obviously and even if let's say that
the Republicans just completely wiped
out the country from all brown people
bad people right let's say that it was
wiped out again another thought
experiment here let's say that these oh
Jesus we just Gabe Sanchez just
committed massages yeah let's no let's
say that like they send everyone back
they send everyone back during your
comments go any other country right it's
down to Mexico to Europe all majority
Europe
let's say that everyone gets sent back
Canada [ __ ] whatever they weren't you
know boom anyone who doesn't look white
they tell them like that look like me
yeah yeah anyone who looks like Tony
they say you're cool you can stay
got you then when you notice that crime
continues uh-huh and violence continues
then they have to stop and realize oh
wait
there must be some brown people yeah but
here's the thing here's the thing here's
the thing Gabe Sanchez is that there
will be no crime from uh bypoc people
people of color right there would be no
crime and that's that's you know it's
the same the same argument for Fentanyl
and again that's why they're like oh the
crime is so much higher in cities but
when you look at per capita there's way
more crime in rural areas way more crime
and rulers but they they can't admit
that because that would you know bang up
their narrative but again the narrative
they're trying to present here is that
brown people are jumping across the wall
with pockets full of fentanyl which is
not happening yeah that's not how it's
that's not even how they're seizing it
they're seizing it at the gate okay
that's where they're [ __ ] seizing the
fennel because the fentanyl that comes
across the borders coming in cars and
the majority of fentanyl that comes in
this country is coming via the Postal
Service not [ __ ] across the border
we've talked about this time and time
again but what they're trying to do is
set the narrative for the immigration
debate which is
that brown people want to come here and
feed your kids Fentanyl and kill the
white children that is what they want
that's why Kevin McCarthy wants to go to
the [ __ ] border and have some kind of
uh I I really
okay back to the whole which one's
Dumber which is a dumber idea Gabe
Sanchez is it Kevin McCarthy going we
should put a poll out on um yeah and our
our pod uh Twitter account which which
idea is which idea is dumber okay so
going going to the border and having a
hearing and shipping all the media
once you tell these okay let's show all
the staff the whole apparatus of having
a hearing which is the reason why we
have Washington DC and the capital and
all the [ __ ] Annex buildings in the
first place
or
is impeaching my orcas
for doing his job essentially you know
because his his department is seizing 14
000 pounds of fentanyl at the Border in
2022. which is a dumber idea
I'll tell you a dumber one
yeah okay so they hold these hearings
yeah whatever these are arbitrary
hearings are down at the border and
while they're at the border
they are the ones to seize the drugs so
now the committee becomes the Department
of Homeland Security so like they got
the guns and [ __ ] and they're like in
the gear because you know the
Republicans would love to put on the
gear and act like they're you know
badasses oh you know the committee
becomes DHS and they're the ones with
the guns using the drugs oh this is the
reason people at the border this this
has potential for a [ __ ] video yeah
I'm thinking yeah absolutely but which
one is dumber I don't I mean in terms of
the original two
I don't know
um
I mean he's really [ __ ] well here's
it well
I would say that uh I don't know because
it's like okay is Lauren bobert's idea
dumb yeah it's [ __ ] dumb but their
plan won't play out how they want
because then Joe Biden will just
nominate someone else
let's say Kevin McCarthy Kevin McCarthy
is dumb and wasteful
like Lauren bobert is just dumb like she
it's like anyone who's like oh we're
gonna impeach Biden okay then Harris
comes in okay we're gonna impeach Harris
okay then Nancy Pelosi would take over
like
they don't understand the actual process
of of of cabinet members and also people
in positions that were nominated you
think it's they don't understand or they
know they're talking to people who don't
understand this
I think it's
I honestly think
it it's not 50 50 but I do think that
some people understand so there's like
saying that [ __ ] to people who think
they know what they're talking about but
then there's those people who are those
people who then were elected into office
who think they know what they're talking
about
and we're just uh they were just kind of
like fueled by these other people who
were already in office trying to be like
oh you know we need to do we need to
impeach this person do that and
meanwhile people like yeah we need to be
and it's like that's
not at all how that works but I look at
that and I say I honestly think
that Lauren bobert's is dumb but Kevin
McCarthy is dumb and wasteful because
it's a lot of taxpayer money so that
could be Dumber
impeachment impeachment hearings would
be expensive now I don't know if you
have the impeachment hearings down at
the border if you had them in Washington
DC so maybe that's how it gets Dumber I
want to go to the the the main story for
today for our title yeah um we had a
couple different choices and and we were
both kind of on the same page that this
should be our uh our title today is that
Rhonda Santa seems to be picking up
steam in these [ __ ] polls again
folks I believe these polls are [ __ ]
this is for a 2024 race in a primary
that's not even close to happening
DeSantis has not even declared there's
no one else declared but the Cheeto desk
you in honor but hey let's politicize
the [ __ ] out of
um this mind [ __ ] that it's gonna happen
to Trump so Chris Webb here um post
this is a graphic from
um the graphic from Morning Joe this
morning on this USA Today poll it's a
2024 a GOP GOP Presidential primaries
America First Nazi party nomination
ceremony
um it has Ron this is crazy because
um a poll from the other day it had
Trump like 30 points ahead that's why I
think these are all [ __ ] [ __ ]
well if you look at you if you look at
the uh at the bottom here it's the
standard deviation is [ __ ] 5.1
percent right so you know if we know
like one two three standard deviations
away like I don't know what the
statistical significance of this poll
was in terms of what they how they ran
it but well we've talked about this
before that these polls are [ __ ]
Antiquated oh yeah they're not they're
not actually getting uh I I believe uh
as as funny as as this is right because
obviously you know we you mentioned
earlier that this is definitely going to
piss Trump off [ __ ] off the rails
maybe that's even posting about it
already I'm gonna check while you're go
ahead uh yeah yeah so I don't know which
came first if the poll came first or the
I've got a special announcement came
first no chicken or the egg type yeah
right like
well let's see that the um
it looks like the the announcer or the
the announcement video was three hours
ago
so I'm not sure when this poll was
actually dropped and if it was on
Morning Joe it was it's possible it was
before three hours so right so now they
will but they would have had to have
that [ __ ] video ready yeah I don't
know I mean like I'm sure somebody just
slops in a or like slots in a graphic
you know and they're like here's the
background here's the thing so I don't
think it's too hard especially if you're
just like Outsourcing something that's
or like if someone's like oh I'm gonna
find this on Fiverr like I guarantee
you'll probably go to Fiverr and
somebody already has like you throw in
the background you don't give everybody
our secrets sometimes yeah yeah right
well here's here's the thing that was
his last post right that was his last
post so he has not posted anything
um but the but the this is this is my
um
my interpretation of Ron DeSantis Ron
DeSantis is uh I believe just another
Scott Walker
well I think Ron DeSantis is gonna pick
he's a weak piece of [ __ ] isn't he dude
he's going to and if anyone doesn't know
the history behind uh Scott Walker it's
too good and how he just like just like
burnt out he even he even won a recall
election and still petered out so
quickly I mean it was actually amazing
to me that right that [ __ ] that
balloon fart that happened with his
campaign it literally was like a balloon
fart well there was also the the you
know for Scott Walker in Wisconsin there
was also the Foxconn development that
happened out there you know Trump was a
part of people don't understand Trump is
a part of this [ __ ] idea and and then
as soon as it [ __ ] uh Foxconn played
Scott Walker and and Wisconsin to be
like yeah we're not gonna We're Not
Gonna promise to make hire this many
people or or put out this much uh
product we're going to do what we need
to do
uh it totally deflated this idea that
Scott Walker had about bringing
thousands and thousands of thousands of
jobs to Wisconsin and and and Trump was
a part of that and ever since that
flailed out he was like nope don't know
the guy never was there never was a part
of it I don't know anything about this
place the guy didn't even make it do the
[ __ ] the Iowa primary did he yeah
a very important question here from
twitch what is a balloon fart it's where
you blow up a balloon like halfway and
then you let that [ __ ] go it's like
that's a balloon fart I just want to
make sure everyone hey this is important
stuff keeps inches this is important
stuff so but uh I want to go back to
what uh the Christopher says here it's
starting to sink in the Republicans and
that Trump can't beat Biden in a
head-to-head and that's the that's the
that's the thing here that Chris points
out that's the real [ __ ] truth here
but they still want trumpism without
Trump so is DeSantis their guy no he's
not uh Biden leads Trump a head-to-head
match 47-40 uh two-thirds of GOP GOP
leaning voters want DeSantis to run
um which again this is all [ __ ] pull
but here's the thing here's what I want
everyone to remember and I said in the
first 30 minutes and I think you agree
with me on this don't [ __ ] worry your
head about the Democratic nominee it
will definitely be Joe Biden there is no
one going to mount any kind of [ __ ]
any kind of primary against one of the
most effective presidents that we've had
in a long time it's just not gonna
happen you're not going there is not a
nominee out there I don't care who they
are even Gavin Newsom he there is no way
Gavin Newsom is going to risk destroying
his [ __ ] political future to possibly
be a president one day right to go up
against one of the most effective
presidents that we've had in a long time
no [ __ ] weight yeah why would you
ever leave especially for you know Gavin
Gavin Newsom like why would you leave
the position no you wouldn't it's dumb
it's real stupid [ __ ] it's the dumbest
it's dumber than [ __ ] having hearings
at the border and impeaching if you want
to you know like we could talk about
2028 that's that's that's a whole
different thing exactly and that's what
I think is is is on the mind around to
Santas okay yeah so this is this is I
think the math here
because this poll because I think
Christopher is a little off the Mark
here when he says so is DeSantis their
guy
I mean they're looking around
but let me tell you something he's the
only one that has been talked about so
in that in that way of thinking sure but
I don't believe that's the case right
well and he does have a question mark
here so I want to give Christian that he
does have a question mark here but
here's what I want to say
this this
poll where Rhonda Santa said if these
polls keep happening this is going to
make Trump the more likely nominee and
the reason why is because if Ronda
Santos is the only one that can mount a
campaign in a Republican primary not
against Biden forget about that [ __ ]
there is an election that has to happen
before they can go against Biden if Ron
DeSantis believes that his political
future is hinged upon beating the chaos
machine that is Trump he will wait till
2028 yeah he will not do it in 2024 he
will not you know and not only that but
like you know for the same reason that
Gavin Newsom won't run also because like
well I'll just say in the state of
California like he you know did a great
job in terms of handling covid we had a
surplus we uh we actually were able to
control things
um and does have
a a solid plan for for just economic
kind of solutions uh but Ron DeSantis
right like even though he was asked
during the debates for the midterm
election
will you run for president in 2024 he
wouldn't answer it because and I think
in some ways it's kind of in the back of
his mind where he's like maybe there's a
chance maybe I decide to [ __ ] run but
his term doesn't renew until January so
what is he gonna just [ __ ] announce
in February or March no he can't he's
got to give it some time which means he
would really only be in his new term for
like I don't know five months six months
before he realistically says I'm gonna
run and then has to do the whole
campaign uh uh like
[ __ ] kissing babies and all that [ __ ]
well here he is on uh Laura Ingram last
night let's see if this topic gets
brought up I think it's just all [ __ ]
science tonight but let's watch learn
today and hearing again these voices
many of them suppressed or people
ostracized over the last few years
well Laura like anything I mean you you
take an m r a shot and the way to view
it is okay what are the benefits and
what are the drops okay I'm not I'm not
even gonna blame the rest of it it's all
science denying um and obviously he's
trying to stay away from the talk of him
being Presidential nominee and the
reason why is because as soon as he's
presumptive Trump is going to burn his
house to the ground and I'm here for it
folks that's what we're here for we need
to draw these wedges Gabe Sanchez I
don't hear it earlier Rachel
bittickoffer is going to be on tomorrow
bam we are going to talk about this very
subject of drawing wedges how do we
drive wedges between these Republicans
it is absolutely crucial for us winning
democracy so stay tuned tomorrow
now here on the Tony Michaels podcast
make sure to subscribe you do not want
to miss tomorrow show Dr Rachel
bittickoff is going to be here so hit
that subscribe button also go to
Twitter if it's still around this
afternoon at Tony Michaels pod we will
be posting the boat another week poll
tomorrow as well and go download every
single episode we'll have the other poll
that we talked about are you gonna put
that one up yeah uh yeah yeah I'll put
it up yeah put it up put up on Twitter
at Tony Michaels pot so go follow if you
want to answer which which one is dumber
which is dumber or maybe we should say
more bone-headed because you know that's
kind of our brand yeah yeah which is
more bone-headed to have a hearing at
the border or to Fire and impeach the
department head who is doing their job
it's really weird
um so everyone stick around tomorrow
it's going to be a great show with
Rachel bitcover and if if we get that
pull up we'll reveal the results of what
is dumber which is more bone-headed
everyone tomorrow same time same place
surf set [ __ ] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
Murphy's mewborn headass Beacon